all of your medical questions about to
be answered right now let's get started
huge thanks to Walmart Plus for
sponsoring this video Pam is it bad that
I can clasp my hands behind my back
no that's good that means you have good
range of motion in fact we do the
special test when we check for shoulder
Mobility called the aptly scratch test
where you reach with both arms we mark
it off we see what your abilities are
and we can understand which part of the
rotator cuff or otherwise is impacted
causing your restriction in motion Max
West how much money do you make enough
to feed Bear for the rest of his life
and get him all the toys his little
heart could ever desire can you develop
an allergy later in life or can you get
over an allergy that you were born with
I'm allergic to my new cat and was
wondering if I'll grow out of it it is
possible prime example people who come
to my office and frequently say they
have a penicillin allergy and we know we
still need to give them penicillin I'll
send them to an allergist and we find
out that a huge percentage it's over 50
have actually grown out of a penicillin
allergy or never had one to begin with
so yes you could absolutely grow out of
them and yes you could absolutely
develop them Heather mikulich what's
happening when my ears pop nothing's
actually popping is it what you're
probably feeling is your eustachian tube
popping which is a very thin tube that
connects your sinuses to your ear and
that tube is actually quite small so if
you have pressure gradients between your
ear and your sinuses especially if
you're going up elevations the popping
feeling is just that eustachian tube
kind of releasing the pressure cow's
milk almond milk skim milk whole milk
fat free which milk do you recommend we
drink it depends to me if you're not
over drinking any of these milks and you
don't have a medical condition you're
probably fine so like drink whichever
one you enjoy especially in moderation
something I will note is like almond
milk doesn't have a lot of nutrition
value it does have some sodium content
so just be wary of that Cecilia Anne
from the Discord what's the deal with a
sugar rush does it really affect kids
and adults differently Sugar Rush made
up grandparents used to see kids eat a
lot of sugar and then be hyper and then
blame it on the sugar that is the prime
example of correlation not causation
kids are hyper after they eat they stay
hyper so it's not the sugar making them
hyper it's their age it's the fact they
have high energy levels nothing to do
with the sugar there is some truth to
sugar causing a crash because after you
eat a lot of sugar your body has to take
that Sugar from your blood and move it
into your cells it does that through
insulin when you get an insulin Spike
you kind of feel a little sleepy a
little bit drowsy a little bit more
tired a sugar crashes real a sugar rush
is not real at all Renee Discord why are
some people able to eat a lot and never
put on weight while other people can put
on weight so quickly metabolism is a big
answer here hormonal systems natural
tendons sees like I'm sitting here and
you can't see my legs but I'm actually
shaking my legs and it's been proven
that those people who sit there and
shake their legs actually burn more
calories throughout the day because it's
a process that happens over a long
period of time so there's a lot of
individual factors that decide someone's
weight the factors that we don't think
about and we don't give enough weight to
is ironic that I said wait twice our
mental health if we're struggling with
depression we may overeat to compensate
to feel better if we're battling with
generalized anxiety disorders we may
under eat because we're so nervous and
not thinking about eating never lose
that component grinding grinding
grinding green grain grain grain I keep
throwing up every time I eat prawn
shrimp crabs scallops oyster crab
lobsters what do I do I was crab listed
twice that's my question but then again
you have grinding three times in your
name so that makes sense what should you
do
don't eat it I know you're probably
saying like do you have a shellfish
allergy or something but while possible
I can't diagnose you based off just that
little factoid what I will say is if you
have true anaphylaxis vomiting can be a
symptom of anaphylaxis I need to know
more lyanna from Discord should I swap
out all white bread rice grains for
brown instead okay so the color thing
about the bread is important to talk
about if you're a person who's looking
to have more fiber in their diet someone
who's looking for better control of
their sugar meaning less spikes less
crashes you're a person that would
probably fare better by having a whole
grain food instead of a white food but
at the end of the day it's still a carb
and if you're overeating carbs even if
they're whole grains you still might run
into a problem so you need to be very
careful when you say this food versus
that food because the question I'll
always ask you right back is why
speaking of nutrition you probably know
that my cholesterol is high and I've
been eating really healthy so I want to
remind you about my partnership with
Walmart plus you see a membership from
them gives you free same-day delivery of
fresh groceries from your local store
they've got high quality ingredients for
your everyday cooking like you're
organic fruits vegetables or even
rotisserie chicken which is one of my
personal favorites with a Walmart plus
membership prices are the same as they
are on the Shelf there are no markups
which means that you have access to the
same fresh high quality food that you're
used to getting from Walmart at
reasonable prices it's perfect for
everything from preparing seasonal
dishes to making a spread on game day or
even filling in the gaps when you've
unexpectedly run out of an ingredient
and believe me the selection is
excellent offering stuff like fresh
sweet potatoes which I like to crisp up
in the oven or even pumpkin spice
because come on it is that season and
once you place an order a specialty
trained Shopper will hand pick the
freshest items organic fruits and
veggies like these apples are pick the
day of the delivery not the day before
so you could really see and taste the
difference they don't just deliver fresh
food products though they also deliver a
lot of what you need for your home and
family like paper towels beauty products
and even some sweet apple cider look
when I tell my patients about the
benefits of a balance and whole food
diet I often hear the struggles they
have with the rising cost of Fresh Foods
and I get that one of the best parts
about a Walmart plus membership is that
they offer high quality quality Fresh
Products at reasonable prices without
hidden fees click the link below to get
started with your free trial now Latoya
how come salt on a slug or something
will kill it but I can have no idea
how would I know about slugs prime time
is it dangerous to eat too much food
because it still contains so much sugar
is it dangerous to consume fruit because
it has sugar I would say no because
there's fiber content there there's
other nutrients there and it's really
hard to like eat 30 Bananas so I think
if you have some foods and you don't
have you know uncontrolled diabetes
you're fine eating sugar that comes from
Plants just stay away from the juices
because when you have one orange that's
like you know whatever 10 grams of sugar
but then when you make a juice you need
to put like six oranges in there to make
a cup full that's a ton of sugar how
much water should I really drink every
day like drinking when you're thirsty
versus just drinking a certain number of
cups a day there is no universal eight
glasses a day two liters a day all that
is nonsense those are like averages that
don't mean anything to you as a human
also something you really really have to
think about is it's not just about
consuming cups of water when you eat
fruit there's water intake in there you
drink tea there's water in there you
even drink soda even though I'm not a
fan there's water in there you're
hydrating yourself so you have to take
all of that into consideration then the
way that I would tell my patients to
judge whether or not they're well
hydrated is through their pee if your
pee is really dark in color with that
would stand with standing without
standing now withstanding having a
medical illness if you're completely
healthy and your urine's dark that means
you could use more water intake if your
urine is clear all the time maybe you
don't need to be drinking so much
because you're over drinking because the
ideal urine color that you want to aim
for is like a pale straw colored yellow
and if it's that all the time you're
doing a great job know that when you're
exercising especially in heat you need
more water know that if you have a fever
you need more water know that if you're
just sitting at home all day maybe you
don't need as much water as when you are
exercising all things to keep in mind
and S can the smell of your sweat tell
you something about your health it can I
have actually a whole video on a woman
who can smell certain illnesses that
goes to show that this knows of ours is
actually not a smell detector well it is
a smell detector but it's really a
chemical detector it can sense certain
compounds in our sweat that when
excreted during illness some people are
sharp enough to pick it up Dom Lopez why
does Gatorade have so much sugar is it
necessary for the Gatorade to work or is
it to taste good Gatorade is a sports
drink it's meant to be consumed during
intense exercise when two things are
happening you're burning a ton of
calories and you're sweating a lot what
do you need to do you need to replace
those calories and you need to replace
your electrolytes Gatorade has both of
those ingredients in there when you
actively run punch lift weights what
you're doing is you're burning the sugar
that is actually in your muscles and
that Sugar needs to be repleted and we
do so by consuming Gatorade now if
you're a person just sitting on the
couch playing a video game and you're
drinking Gatorade you're essentially
taking all that sugar and just storing
it and not actively using it so it can
be a source of unnecessary weight gain
for individuals aurex 449 what's better
for your health real meat or fake meat
if I think they both taste just as good
should I eat one over the other such an
individualized question because it
depends on what your goals are what
you're looking to achieve that being
said there is a myth being propagated
right now stating that all vegan meat is
actually super healthy that's not true
true are there benefits to eating
plant-based Meats yeah absolutely better
for the environment you're not consuming
animal products less cholesterol in
there at the end of the day a
plant-based Burger is still a burger
there's still a ton of salt in there
preservatives it still technically falls
into the category of junk food don't put
it into the category of health food
because it's not agent orange 666. what
are some ways for me to stop snoring a
find out why you're snoring there's
multiple reasons B if you have sleep
apnea and you get diagnosed with it you
could use a CPAP machine which
essentially keeps pressure in your
Airway even when you're relaxed in order
to prevent it from collapsing and
causing you to wake up from a lack of
breathing Michael I'm taking antibiotics
should I eat a probiotic yogurt C yes
yes da yes we yes I wish I knew more
languages
um you should in fact I tell my patients
that when they are on antibiotics that
they should either take a probiotic or a
yogurt or kimchi or sauerkraut because
it replaces some of the good bacteria
that's negatively impacted by the
antibiotics you're taking remember
antibiotics Target only bacteria not
viruses is not fun guy but you have
bacteria in your body that actually
helps you live helps you get nutrition
out of food lives on your skin and
prevents the overgrowth of bad bacteria
when you take antibiotics they don't
discriminate they kill the good stuff
along with the bad stuff so you want to
replace the good stuff by taking a
probiotic how often should you be
showering turns out you might be
showering too much click here to find
out and again huge thanks to Walmart
Plus for sponsoring today's video visit
the link in the description to start
your free trial now and as always stay
happy and healthy